[Música]
el presidente de manuel mayo oficializó
finalmente de su aspiración a la
reelección en francia y realizó sus
primeros actos de campaña
los otros candidatos galos se meten en
su contra por no participar en los
debates electorales les detallamos los
acontecimientos más destacados de los
últimos días en la contienda electoral
francés
entonces son los candidatos oficiales a
la presidencia de francia el consejo
constitucional publicó la lista de
quienes lograron recolectar más de 500
avales por parte de funcionarios ya
electos les contaremos quienes
competirán para llegar al palacio del
elíseo
y la guerra en ucrania está incidiendo
de las elecciones francesas en sus
discursos los candidatos están tomando
posturas a favor o en contra de darle
más armas a kiev y algunos se acercan al
kremlin en esta emisión analizaremos
quién se favorece electoralmente con la
crisis
bienvenidos a este programa especial
sobre las elecciones en francia yo soy
maría clara calle y comencemos con un
resumen de lo más reciente en la campaña
electoral gala el presidente de manuel
ma com esperó hasta el último momento
posible para anunciar su aspiración a la
reelección ocupado por la guerra en
ucrania un tema que ha cobrado cada vez
mayor importancia entre los
precandidatos los aspirantes están
divididos sobre si entregar más armas a
kiev o que hacer frente a los refugiados
incluso algunos aspirantes al elíseo
inclinan su balanza hacia el kremlin y
trabajan con personas que respaldan a
vladimir putin veamos el recuento
[Música]
al slavia que desde me ha estado
buscando más que cualquier otro político
que haya logrado alejar del partido de
marín open majestad es la sobrina del
open y también es ex diputada
y parece una sirena
me voy a este derecho
no yo
estoy completamente convencida que el
ics tiene la mayor posibilidad de ganar
esta elección tiempo récord de ustedes
han empezado a construir esta gran unión
de derecha que eric logra hacer vivir
cada día
tiene la esperanza de recuperar los
puntos que ha perdido en las encuestas
debido a sus posiciones pro rusas johnny
que lo son también fue acusado de ser
blando en su postura ante vladimir putin
el candidato izquierdista aún quiere que
francia abandone la otan y se opone a
enviar armas a ucrania pero ha
endurecido su retórica respecto a rusia
para que detengan la guerra detenga la
invasión de ucrania abajo el ejército
que está invadiendo ucrania
a diferencia de -1 y anisados del
partido verde tradicionalmente pacifista
quiere entregar más armas a ucrania
[Aplausos]
a la vez
debemos respaldar y seguir armando a la
resistencia ucraniana nos alegró mucho
en francia en aquellos tiempos donde los
ingleses y estadounidenses armaron a la
resistencia francesa
[Música]
los candidatos están divididos sobre la
cuestión de los refugiados y frank ya no
hace mucho dice que algunos podrían
venir bajo ciertas condiciones
lópez dice que abriría más la puerta
pero sólo temporalmente
podemos recibir a mujeres y niños que
están huyendo no recibiremos los
mantendremos a salvo hasta que la guerra
termine
la familia bushel resaltó que la extrema
derecha no era tan tolerante con los
refugiados provenientes de siria igual a
tú te limite duro disco vemos las
limitaciones de su política como si
fuese legítimo y escoger a los
refugiados basados en la guerra de la
que usen los países de los que vienen
uso de uso dio dulce llega mientras se
mantiene enfocado en la guerra en gran
ya emmanuel makoun se tomó un tiempo
para lanzar su campaña con un elaborado
vídeo promocional el candidato debe ser
capaz de presentar su proyecto a la
nación pero un presidente también debe
ser capaz de hacer su trabajo ustedes
pueden llamarme señor candidato
[Música]
para los rivales de makoun no hay una
razón válida que impida que el
presidente francés participe en un
debate de un
kilo
los resultados de manuel macro no son en
realidad una falta de resultados
necesitamos un debate democrático está
no tener un debate democrático proyecto
contando josé jorge por otro lado la
tradicional feria agrícola fue una
oportunidad de mostrar las habilidades
de baile de los candidatos joven tomó la
iniciativa seguida por the move mientras
tanto yo la sal que se presenta como
hombre del pueblo no pudo ser más
amistoso con las multitudes eso es todo
por ahora amigos hasta la próxima semana
los candidatos tuvieron hasta el 4 de
marzo para presentar ante el consejo
constitucional los 500 avales de cargos
electos para validar sus aspiraciones
algunos se quedaron por fuera como la ex
ministra de justicia cristian t oveja
aquí les contamos quiénes son los 12
contenedores la carrera por el palacio
del elíseo ha empezado a sus 44 años el
actual mandatario de manuel mayo busca
un segundo período el centrista pro
europeo lidera en las encuestas a pesar
de una presidencia marcada por la
agitación social estos tres candidatos
de derechas son sus principales
contendores madryn de penn la aspirante
de la extrema derecha que perdió la
segunda vuelta en 2017 con macul
ella va cabeza a cabeza en las encuestas
con el ex de moore un ex comentarista de
televisión que se convirtió en otra
opción de la extrema derecha su discurso
polarizante anti migratorio ayuda a la
candidata conservadora valérie pécresse
a inclinarse aún más hacia la derecha
ella se autodenomina la dama de hierro
francesa la mejor esperanza de la
izquierda parece ser yuc - o el político
de 70 años es el único candidato
izquierdista con dos dígitos en las
encuestas muy por encima de su antiguo
aliado el comunista fabián hoss el rego
siguen ya ni cuando el ecologista y anne
hidalgo la alcaldesa socialista de parís
y los dos candidatos trotskistas natalia
esto y philip tutu finalmente dos
contendores de 2017 están de vuelta en
los bloques iniciales nicolás vivo en
yum fuertemente euroescéptico y ron la
sal que antes trabajaba como pastor sus
posibilidades de ser elegidos son
escasas pero estos candidatos que
parecen al margen atraerán una cantidad
considerable de votos especialmente
entre ciudadanos desilusionados que sólo
tienen dos opciones más anular el voto o
la abstención
luego de tener a los candidatos de
cantados las tendencias en las encuestas
se mantienen el sondeo del 11 de marzo
the keep partners muestra de nuevo al
actual presidente de manuel bajó a la
delantera con 30 por ciento de la
intención de voto esto es 13 puntos
porcentuales por encima de la diputada
ma jin led en la conservadora vale gip g
es el ultraderechista eriksen y el
socialista joan lerma nation empatan con
12% los demás candidatos están por
debajo del 10% pero si los aspirantes
más opcionados pasar a la segunda vuelta
del 24 abril mayo le ganaría al epen con
el
59% de los votos
y ante este panorama muchos analistas
estiman que una de las razones por las
que marco puede tener la delantera es
por el protagonismo que ha tenido
mediando en la guerra en ucrania de
hecho la encuestadora key partners
incluyó ese tema por primera vez dentro
de la pregunta de que le importa más a
los franceses al votar sin embargo el
conflicto ruso-ucraniano quedó de cuarto
lugar por debajo de otros como el poder
adquisitivo o la protección social
aún así flojo razón que no director del
grupo de investigación en relaciones
internacionales
américa latina e integración de la
pontificia universidad javeriana en
bogotá sostiene que los tiempos de
dificultades benefician a los
mandatarios escuchemos
efectivamente las períodos de crisis son
siempre para el provecho de la persona
que está asumiendo el poder en el
momento en el cual esta crisis será
emanuel makoun ha
aprovechado en los sondeos está dinámica
una dinámica de
reagrupamiento alrededor de la bandera
podríamos decir y ganó en los últimos
días unos 85 puntos porcentuales
en los sondeos pero esta dinámica no es
solamente para el presidente de francia
es también el caso para la progresión
son en gran bretaña y también yo vaivén
en eeuu
el punto central aquí es qué mckeown se
presenta entonces a 30 días de las
elecciones con una ventaja que ha sido
muy pocas veces vista
en las elecciones presidenciales
francesas y tenemos que remontarnos a
1988 para ver niveles de popularidad tan
altos para un presidente saliente hasta
aquí nuestro programa nos vemos el otro
sábado a las 8 30 de la noche ahora
bogotá quito lima para nuestro nuevo
episodio sobre qué está pasando en las
elecciones presidenciales de francia
hasta entonces
[Música]